Santa Claus has long been the symbol of Christmas,
bringing joy and presents to all the good
girls and boys. But if you are child in Germany,
Austria, and other parts of the Alps region,
there may be something much more dark, mischievous,
and grumpy hidden in the shadows next to dear
old St. Nick. That something is Krampus, the
Christmas demon.
A beast-like creature with fangs, fur, and
horns, Krampus announces his presence with
loud bells and terrorizes the kids who have
been naughty during the year. While Santa
gives the good ones gifts and joy, Krampus
gives the bad ones beatings with a whip (made
from birch sticks and horsehair) and nightmares.
As for the really, really naughty kids, Krampus
drops them in a sack (or a wicker basket on
his back) and whisks them away to his lair
– which is of course the underworld – never
to be seen again.
So how did this mythological beast come to
be a part of this region’s Christmas tradition?
High up in the Alp countries of Europe is
where Krampus was born, or, more accurately,
where the legend was created. The word “Krampus”
is derived from the Old High German word krampen,
meaning “claw.” According to Norse mythology,
Krampus is the son of Hel, the goddess ruler
of the underworld. There are also a few physical
similarities between Krampus and Greek mythical
creatures – like the horns and hoofs of
satyrs and fauns.
Scholars estimate that Krampus started appearing
around the 13th century, if not earlier – perhaps
in the 11th century. Originating in Southern
Germany and Austria (the area known as Bavaria),
the creature moved to other European countries
such as Switzerland, Czech Republic, Hungary,
and even the Alp villages of Italy, sometimes
with variations on the name and practiced
customs. For example, in Tyrol (a state in
western Austria), Krampus tends to look like
a giant, sadistic, teddy bear. In western
Germany, he actually arrives with Santa, sitting
shotgun in his sleigh. In Styria (southeast
Austria), the birch sticks used for his whip
are painted gold and displayed year around,
to remind kids of Krampus’s impending arrival.
According to Al Ridenour, director of Krampusfest
LA and in an article he wrote for Atlas Obscura,
this is due to the regions’ isolation and
each communities’ interpretation of Krampis.
Said Ridenour,
“Long before the circulation of any (art)
standardizing the image, the isolating Alpine
terrain of Krampus’ native habitat encouraged
strong regional variations. And without any
grounding source text to nail down his appearance,
the original Krampus would have been a shapeless
bogeyman defined only by oral tradition, a
freeform figure variously described by parents
and other storytellers.”
As Christianity took over the region, Krampus
wasn’t forgotten, but rather altered to
match changing customs. No longer thought
of as a pagan tradition, he was given chains,
to show the “devil” being binded by the
Church. Soon, Krampus was attached to St.
Nick, a Christian saint and the owner of his
very own feast day (or celebration) on December
6th. St. Nick, himself, wouldn’t be closely
associated with Christmas until early 19th
century with the name Santa Claus coming from
the Dutch of the protracted words for St.
Nicholas.
In many parts of Germany and Austria, St.
Nick is still separate from Christmas and
celebrated on December 6th. To further the
connection between the two, Krampus was awarded
his own night on December 5th, the day before
St. Nick’s feast (the same evening when
kids would put a boot outside, hoping St.
Nick drops fruit and nuts into it). Called
Krampusnacht (Krampus Night), Krampus bounds
around making loud noises and scaring kids.
This night is still celebrated in the Alps
region with it being customary to offer Krampus
a drink of warm schnapps.
Despite these attachments to Christianity,
some pagan traditions have survived and are
still part of today’s Krampus. To wit, he
continues to carry bells, which were customarily
used to ward off spirits. As mentioned, the
animal-like appearance of most Krampus’
also date to pagan times.
Krampus, along with other German pagan legends,
started to regain acceptance and a following
in the 19th century. This was partially due
to the ancient German folk tales that the
Brothers Grimm popularized in the early 1800s.
In fact, Krampus gets a quick reference in
Jacob Grimm’s 1835 book Deutsche Mythologie
(translated to “Teutonic Mythology”).
Art and postcards were also created that showed
off Krampus and people began to exchange Krampus
cards (with some saying “Greetings from
the Krampus”) in Europe during the late
19th century as a rather peculiar way of saying
“happy holidays.” They tended to be kitschy
in nature, even with somewhat sexual overtones
such as a Krampus scaring a good-looking,
half-dressed woman.
Krampus hasn’t always been an accepted European
tradition. In 1934, four years before the
Third Reich overran Germany and Austria, The
New York Times ran an article with the headline,
“Krampus Disliked in Fascist Austria; Gienel
Black and Red Devil, Symbol of Christmas Fun,
Is Frowned Upon.” The article goes on to
say how the Austrian Fascist government outlawed
Krampus, even going so far as claiming he
was socialist. When the fascist government
fell after World War II, Krampus was allowed
to walk the streets once again.
More recently, Krampus has started his rise
in popularity in America, with Krampus festivals
across the country, including ones in Los
Angeles, Philadelphia, and New York City.
So, next time someone says “happy holidays”
to you, feel free to greet them back with
“May Krampus not take your child away
in
a basket.”